image d'unité qui a déjà fait le tour de
l'europe le chef du gouvernement italien
mario draghi le président français
emmanuel macron et le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz ensemble à mort
d'un train pour kiev première visite en
ukraine pour les trois dirigeants des
trois premières économies européennes
depuis le début de la guerre à irbine
près de kiev ils sont venus constater
les dégâts la ville a été bombardée sans
relâche par les russes elle est
aujourd'hui partiellement détruite
ils ont détruit des garderies les
terrains de jeux et tout sera
reconstruit ils ont déjà commencé
d'une seule et même voix les trois
dirigeants européens veulent surtout
l'assuré ils continueront de soutenir
l'ukraine sans relâche notamment via les
livraisons d'art dans la france est aux
côtés de l'ukraine de huit premiers
juges turcs l'armée ukrainienne le
reconnaît avec les césar français tout
particulièrement qui sont moins très
utile ensuite par le soutien financier
nous avons commencé européen apporter du
financement pour reconstruire les villes
qui ont été touchés une visite
symbolique qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir la russie le kremlin juge futile
ses livraisons d'armes aux occidental à
l'ukraine